- [Narrator] The Supreme Court
has a lot of controversial
cases on its docket,
whether domestic abusers
should have access to guns,
whether the Consumer
Financial Protection Bureau
is constitutional, and if the
abortion pill should be legal.
All of these cases come
from one lower court,
the same one that also
sent the court big cases
about the Affordable
Care Act and abortion.
It's the US court of appeals
for the Fifth Circuit,
arguably the most conservative
appeals court in the country.
And strangely, even though
they're bringing a conservative
Supreme Court conservative cases,
their most pressing rulings
are being overturned a lot.
- You have case after case
where the Fifth Circuit had
done something that was too far
to the right or too procedurally extreme
even for this Supreme Court.
- [Narrator] That's Stephen Vladeck,
a professor and legal scholar.
- The Federal appeals courts
are perhaps the most powerful
institution that we spend
the least time talking about
in our public discourse,
- [Narrator] And he'll help us explain
how the Fifth Circuit
became the go-to place
for controversial cases
and why so many are making
it to the Supreme Court.
There are 12 appeals courts
representing different parts
of the country, and their judges,
just like Supreme Court
justices, are nominated
by the President and
confirmed by the Senate.
That used to involve getting 60 votes
and the approval of the senators
from the state they'd be representing.
So there was some bipartisanship needed.
- You had really this long
period of time where most,
not all, but most of the
federal judges being confirmed
by the Senate were, you know,
maybe a little right of center,
a little left of center,
but pretty centrist.
- [Narrator] Today, not so much.
For example, President Trump was able
to appoint several judges
to the Fifth Circuit
who are different.
- The judges are, I think,
on anyone's placement
pretty far to the right.
- [Narrator] That's
because the process shifted
during the Trump administration.
2017, the Senate changed
the rules so that nominees
only needed 50 or 51 votes to be confirmed
and no longer cared about the
home state senator's approval.
So judicial nominees no longer
needed bipartisan support.
- You're seeing the sort of the norm
for judicial confirmation be, you know,
who is the most
ideologically extreme person
I can get through the Senate today.
For obvious reasons that
changes the calculus
for what kind of person
you're looking for.
- [Narrator] So Trump nominated judges
and justices who had.
- Extensive and controversial records.
- [Narrator] Unlike previous
appeals court judges
who typically had backgrounds
in private practice
or as judges in other courts,
most of Trump's judges, at
least in the Fifth Circuit,
also had political backgrounds
either working for
campaigns, the White House,
or directly for the Governor
and Attorney General
they now hear cases from.
- I actually think that many of the judges
that we're seeing nominated
during the Trump administration
and confirmed during the
Trump administration,
and indeed many of the
judges we're seeing nominated
during the Biden administration
and confirmed today,
would never have been nominated
during prior presidencies
of the same party.
And you know, I think folks
will have different views about
whether that's a good
thing or a bad thing.
What I think we can't deny is it's a thing
and it's having a pretty
profound effect on the nature
of the federal judiciary.
- [Narrator] But the
judges alone can explain
the controversial cases.
They don't make them up.
- Part of it is litigants
steering cases to these judges.
The modus operandi is to file in Texas
where you can find a
sympathetic district judge
and where you know that any appeal
is going to the Fifth Circuit.
- [Narrator] The case
against the abortion pill
was filed in Amarillo, Texas
because the district judge there,
the court that hears the cases
before the appeals court does
is very conservative.
Dobbs was brought in Mississippi
and the Fifth Circuit judges
can even make the system work
in their interest.
When a case comes to the court of appeals,
it's assigned to a panel
of three random judges.
At the Fifth Circuit,
the odds are pretty good
that a case will be heard
by a majority of conservative judges.
But sometimes a case gets a
majority of liberal judges,
like with a case involving whether felons
should have the right
to vote in Mississippi.
The panel ruled they should,
but the full court can
decide to rehear cases
by the entire court what's called en banc,
which it plans to do for
that felons one in January.
- Folks tend to use the
term judicial activism
as a shorthand for decisions
they disagree with,
and I think that in that
respect, the term is unhelpful.
There is, however, I think
something that is especially
aggressive about the way the
Fifth Circuit's behaving,
not just in the substance of the decisions
that the court's handing down,
but also just in its procedural behavior.
So one great example of
this was the challenges
to the Biden administration's vaccination
or testing mandate for large employers.
- [Narrator] Immediately,
dozens of nearly identical
lawsuits challenging the rule were filed
in different states.
So many that every circuit
court in the country
would've heard the same case.
It triggered a literal lottery.
Each court with a pending
case would have a ball
put into a wooden drum and
whoever had theirs picked out
would hear the case.
But before that lottery happened,
the Fifth Circuit cut ahead
and ruled on the case anyway,
blocking the Biden
administration's mandate.
After the lottery, the
winning court reversed it
and allowed the policy to go into effect.
- It's not just that you have
judges all the way to one side
of the ideological spectrum
who are being aggressive
in adopting and pushing
for new interpretations
of what had been pretty
settled legal concepts.
It's that they're taking
procedural shortcuts,
and I think that's part of
why we're seeing increasingly
a disconnect between
the conservative judges
on the Fifth Circuit
and the conservative justices
on the Supreme Court,
you know, some of whom I
think are much more particular
about those procedural formalities.
- [Narrator] President
Trump was able to appoint
a large number of polarizing judges.
President Biden has done some of the same
thanks to that 50 vote
rule, but not as polarizing
as the Democratic Senate has mostly taken
the home state approval rule back up.
- I think the real problem
at the end of the day
is you might be happy
with individual results
and individual cases,
but our legal system is
not set up for a world
in which you can have
this kind of radical polls
with no middle.
What that really is a recipe for is chaos
and not a set of coherent,
uniform, legal principles
that actually might allow
us to function as one nation
as opposed to 50 different states.
- [Narrator] With the Fifth Circuit
filled with conservative judges,
it will continue to attract
the most conservative cases,
some of which will inevitably
end up at the Supreme Court.
(dramatic music)